in the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion for August 22, on which we commemorate the holy martyr,
Elalia of Barcelona, Saint Elalia lived near Barcelona in Spain, where she was brought
up to be very devout.
When she was twelve years old, the bloodthirsty Dacian, an emissary of the co-emperors'
Diocletian and Maximian, who had been charged with applying the edicts of persecution against
the Christians, arrived in the region, exulting within herself with a divine joy, Elalia
secretly left the family house and went straight to Dacian's tribunal.
As she confessed the name of Christ with a boldness that surprised the tyrant, he thought
that to make her submit, it would be enough to make her look ridiculous.
So he had her carried around the city, on the shoulders of a soldier, while another whipped
her with a rod.
Yet, far from fleeing humiliated, Elalia radiated a holy pride, and the faithful, seen
her pass admired the constancy given her by the Lord.
Seething with anger, the judge had her stripped and tied by his men to a grill, so that her
flesh could be torn with iron combs, and then burned with torches.
As the young girl mocked her torturers, laughing at their powerlessness, she was thrown into
a pit of burning straw, into which burning oil and melted lead were poured.
Yet none of these torturers succeeded in overcoming the heavenly joy which the grace of God gave
her, making her oblivious to her bodily sufferings.
She was then tied to a cross, and those present soon witnessed her victorious soul take flight
to heaven, in the form of a white dove.
Saint Elalia was venerated as the patron of the city of Barcelona, and her fame spread
throughout Spain and the whole of the south of France.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's O Lord, Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us,
and save us.